one of the key criteria to being
successful in investing is to always
learn from the past and as we saw in the
2008 2009 financial crisis the housing
market fell off a cliff but if we
actually go back and we look as to why
this occurred it's actually quite
compelling as you can see here in this
chart back in 2008 2009 that red line
shows that housing was exploding upwards
in value and all of a sudden starting in
about 2004 the federal reserve decided
to raise interest rates the federal
funds effective rate went through the
roof going up over four and a half
percent and what followed very closely
after was that housing prices collapsed
you continue to see that red line trend
downwards now if you look all the way to
the far right you can see that housing
prices have been exploding upwards and
in that blue line you see that the
federal fund's effective rate is
starting to creep upwards now coming
close to 1.5 percent as we see the
federal funds rate continue to climb
higher and higher it increases the odds
that there could be some sort of housing
collapse now just because in the past
housing prices went up and then federal
fund rates went up meant that it crashed
that doesn't mean that it's going to
happen in the future but what we do have
to be careful of is that u.s housing is
definitely in the danger zone the odds
are increasing that there could be a
housing market collapse what you need to
understand is how to be prepared in a
bull or bear scenario housing prices
going to the moon are definitely a
function of loose monetary policy and so
much money sloshing around an economy
looking for a place to be stored to
protect themselves from that nine plus
percent inflation that is being
experienced in the united states but if
the federal reserve is going to continue
to aggressively raise rates and they are
going to conduct quantitative tightening
naturally housing demand is going to
fall and if housing demand falls
prices usually follow keep your head on
a swivel stay educated and make sure
you're prepared housing prices are the
highest they've ever been in the united
states both for brand new homes and the
average american home so naturally
there's a reversion to the mean
which means you just need to be prepared
to be able to weather the bad times